[Music]  Casa Roseanne is together again  death makes me want to save hours after  ABC officially announced the plans for  an eight-episode reboot of the hit 90  sitcom on Tuesday Roseanne Barr John  Goodman and the rest of the cast  reunited during the ABC up fronts  presentation in NYC the cast cozied up  on the famous Conner family couch 20  years after the show ended in May of  1997 giving us a major throwback moment  Roseanne dished on her feelings about  bringing the show back telling the crowd  quote I'm happy to be here we've got a  whole lot more to say this is going to  be fun what do you think of the Conner  family coming back to television and  will John Goodman's character Dan be  alive in the reboot we sure hope so but  let us know your thoughts over on  Twitter at ET now